2 % de hausse analyse déprimé diop en
octobre
cinq ans après la loi sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse de nouveau à
l'assemblée jacques chirac votre fera
contre le projet de monsieur bonsoir les
chinois moscou c'est un raccourci un peu
rapide pour vous dire que les athlètes
chinois participeront l'année prochaine
aux jeux olympiques qui vous le savez
doivent se dérouler dans la capitale
soviétique
ceci parce que depuis deux heures le
comité international olympique a réuni
en son sein le comité olympique chinois
par 62 voix contre 17 les chinois
reviennent ainsi en force dans le
mouvement olympique après 21 ans
d'absence alors pourquoi un milliard
d'habitants elle est ainsi tenu à
l'écart des compétitions internationales
du plus haut niveau
et bien tout simplement parce que la
place était prise jusqu alors par forme
aux formes aux que le seuil haut sommes
maintenant d'accepter la relégation à un
rang de comité régional de plus les
autorités olympiques lui demande d'abord
donné son drapeau et son hymne national
formose n'a guère le choix sinon c'est
l'exclusion pure et simple du mouvement
olympique
nous verrons donc les chinois à moscou
et dès cet hiver alec pc mais pour
autant il ne faut pas s'attendre à des
performances exceptionnelles sauf en de
rares domaines plus de 30 millions de
licenciées c'est la principale force du
sport chinois une marais qui risque dans
l'avenir de bouleverser la hiérarchie du
sport mondial
car les chinois ont préparé ce retour
dans le giron olympique
en octobre ils ont organisé notamment
leurs quatrièmes jeux nationaux depuis
leur révolution
une revue d'effectif un peu décevant
avec un seul record du monde battu le
tir au pigeon féminin les dirigeants
chinois ont décidé d'envoyer à moscou
300 athlètes qui auront donc la
possibilité de se situer au niveau
international ce sera aussi pour la
chine l'occasion de s'affirmer grâce au
sport
bien sûr à lake placid les chinois n'ont
que peu de chances de briller à moscou
pour les jeux d'été
ce sera différent ainsi en gymnastique
ils peuvent remporter des médailles
d'ailleurs à ce sujet nous en saurons
plus ce dimanche lors des championnats
du monde à dallas en tirer ce crime et
haltérophilie
les chinois seront également compétitif
pour l'athlétisme et la natation les
deux sports vedette s'est en revanche
l'inconnu toutefois il est possible
qu'un athlète chinois réussissent un
exploit car il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
y a dix ans ni chichis battait le record
du monde du saut en hauteur avec 2
mètres 29 moscou sera donc un test pour
le sport chinois qui pourrait accueillir
en 88 les jeux dans ce stade des
ouvriers de pékin la chine au jeu un
nouveau péril jaune
si on veut s'il en est encore dans
l'incertitude sur les performances des
chinois à moscou on sait déjà le temps
qu'il fera ce moment là bas dans la
capitale soviétique selon la météo russe
qui prend beaucoup de paris le temps
sera frais et sec avec beaucoup de vent
donc pour juillet-août il rend toujours
pas de développement spectaculaire
malgré la mission du parlementaire
américain george benson qui a pu
rencontrer les otages que voici
ils sont vous le savez une quarantaine
la maison blanche s'est d'ailleurs
déclarée opposée à la mission
personnelle entreprises par leurs
représentants en estimant qu'il risquait
de prolonger la détention des otages
toutes ces initiatives individuelles y
la maison blanche risque de donner aux
autorités iraniennes des idées fausses
sur les intentions du gouvernement
américain et puis pour l'instant
l'ayatollah khomeini lancé un nouvel
appel à la préparation de la guerre
sainte qui doit être engagée at il dit
sur le plan religieux financier et
militaire
toutes ces déclarations sont bien sûr de
nature à aggraver la tension dans cette
région du monde et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons interrogé un
spécialiste britannique des problèmes
stratégiques
c'est une situation sans précédent il ya
un bilan des autorités qui sont pas des
autorités on ne sait pas avec qui
négocier avec qui parler sur qui met la
pression
donc on se trouve
devant un pays dans le chaos c'est
précisément ce problème là on ne peut
pas parler on peut pas dialoguer
négocier qui rend la situation si un
prédictible mais essayons de comparer le
degré d'intensité cette crise avec
d'autres crises par exemple cuba en 1962
ou le proche-orient 1973 est-ce que là
on était plus près d'une guerre
qu'aujourd'hui ou est ce au contraire en
été - près d'une situation très
dangereuse parce que des du côté il y
avait des gens qui étaient dans leur
propre définition des gens rationnels
donc il était un élément de
prédictibilité qui est nécessaire pour
le conflit qu management
dans la situation actuelle ça qui manque
et c'est pour ça que il est tellement
important de ne pas paniquer de
continuer la pression mais de ne pas
faire dans un sens de la part des
américains qui naquit kiki qui ferme la
porte pour le pur pour attirer on se
trouve devant d'un pays dans un état de
cross
on a l'intérêt de libérer les otages
on n'a pas intérêt à déclencher une
guerre mais c'était christophe bertranne
qui est directeur des instituts d études
stratégiques et la guerre sera le thème
de questions dans notre magazine qui
suit ce journal à 20h35 donc question de
temps animé par louis blériot et georges
bortoli appuyé par les témoignages de
très nombreux spécialistes et
correspondant du monde entier edgard
pisani michel pays de ski albin
chalandon et le jeune à reuters
en direct de washington seront parmi ses
invités et puis pour être tout à fait
complet avec le dossier iranien il faut
y ajouter la prudente condamnation
chinoise de la prise d'otages de
l'ambassade américaine voilà trois
semaines que pékin est aisé de
télégrammes de l'étranger encore d'abord
la confirmation qu'il n'y a aucun
survivant dans l'avion pakistanais qui
s'est écrasé en arabie saoudite
tous les membres d'équipage et 155
pèlerins qui revenaient de la mecque ont
donc ainsi trouvé la mort pour une
raison inexpliquée
on exclut quand même pour l'instant un
attentat qui serait pas en relation avec
prise de la mosquée de la mecque prises
qui n'est toujours pas terminée et puis
sachez que les autorités turques
craignent un attentat contre le pape qui
arrive dans trois jours à istanbul
l'assassin présumé d'un journaliste cdh
évadé de prison et il a écrit aux
journaux son intention de tuer jean paul
ii
cette affaire française maintenant avec
tout d'abord la hausse des prix pour le
mois d'octobre une hausse bien forte 1,2
pour cent très moyen des ministres rené
monory
on a envie de dire près-midi york
philippe sassier vous savez l'indicé des
prix du mois d'octobre n'est jamais bon
en cause des loyers
ils font valoir tout à l'heure
l'inflation s'est accélérée dans le
monde occidental depuis quelques mois
alors en france d'abord 1,2 pour cent
les prix dans l'industrie ont augmenté
de 1,2 pour cent elle ma passion de 1%
bardon fait l'alimentation qu 1,2 pour
cent y actuellement une tension sur les
prix alimentaires et qui inquiète
certains des spécialistes et ce sont les
services avec 1,3 pour cent quand en
quelque sorte le ruban bleu de
l'inflation notamment à cause des loyers
d'une façon générale les services
augmente assez rapidement et nord du
port le mois d'octobre réussi par mois
d'octobre si vous le voulez bien on va
regarder entre janvier et octobre
79 de combien à l'inflation s'est
accélérée dans le monde
alors ces chiffres là que sont pas les
chiffres de la hausse des prix c'est ce
qu'est de supérieur par rapport au
rythme qui est enregistré en 1970 et
vous les états unis et bien la hausse
des prix de 3,1 pour cent supérieur à
1978 toujours entre janvier et octobre
en allemagne fédérale de 3 4% en france
1,6 pour cent
ceci est pas mauvais ça signifie que
l'afrique des prix en france ne
s'accélère pas aussi vite qu'ailleurs
ils ont la principauté depuis au camp
mais la france partait de plus haut
c'est exact l'italie 6,3 pour cent sont
quand même des choses qui sont assez
inquiétantes et ça veut dire que l'an
prochain il y aura toujours des tensions
sur les prix qu'il faudra essayer de
supprimer y avait quand même une bonne
nouvelle sur le bureau de rené monory et
de jean françois deniau la troisième
place que la france a chipé aux japonais
en matière de l'expression exportations
effectivement c'est que pour l'instant
on arrive quand même pas en vendant des
produits made in france appuie
complètement notre facture pétrolière où
la paix grâce à l'exportation qu'on ne
voit pas c'est tout ce qui est le
tourisme sont les assurances et ses
terres lanfains regarder les
exportations de la france en 1973 un peu
plus de 62 milliards
162 milliards et demi exactement en 79
combattent un cd un chiffre de
prévisions 417 milliards oui vous l'a
quand même fait des progrès assez alors
maintenant voilà le palmarès un lien la
médaille d'or aux états unis près de 16
milliards ce sont des dollars
on sait ce dont bayard avait nourri pour
ces trois mois août septembre octobre en
exportations l'allemagne fédérale vient
juste derrière les etats-unis oui vous
mais les allemands exporte très très
fort 14 7 milliards toujours en dollars
et la france oui vous s'adjuge la
médaille de bronze en est question quand
même loin elle est française ou quand
même loin derrière les allemands enfin
près de 9 milliards et nous battons une
courte tête qui respirait de brest les
japonais avec 8,8 milliards petite
satisfaction donné satisfaction
sachez aussi que puisque nous parlions
pris les pneus ont augmenté à partir
d'aujourd'hui chez michelin et à partir
du 10 décembre chez pull & bear colombes
d'à peu près 5 % y compris les pneus
roszak et el moubarki recevait ce matin
andré berges on lui a dit que l'on
s'acheminait vers un taux d'inflation de
11,2 à 11,3 pour cette année mais qui ne
devrait pas dépasser les 10% l'an
prochain sauf accident imprévisible
il lui a par ailleurs confirmé que par
décret on allait se diriger vers les
quarante six heures maximum de travail
par semaine 46 au lieu de 48
raymond barre qui venait de se rendre au
chevet de son mini du travail jean
matteoli hospitalisé comme le premier
ministre il ya dix jours au val de grâce
à la suite vous le savez d'un infarctus
hier après midi à son domicile parisien
l'intérim de monsieur matteoli n'est pas
prévu pour l'immédiat
jean matteoli du fond de son lit aura
quand même pu se réjouir de la reprise
du travail ce matin chez alstom la
mission de son médiateur ranger salma y
est un peu pour quelque chose en régaler
avec eux avec une équipe d'antenne 2 la
reprise du travail au terme de deux mois
de grève
à belfort allez voir qu'il se dégage de
ce reportage une atmosphère très
particulière
en coupe de france ce dimanche le stade
municipal belfortain recevait cinq
l'autre des tribunes clairsemées pour
assister à la victoire de l'équipe
locale 2 à 0 façon jurassien en
reprenant le chemin du stade jean claude
regnault retrouver un peu de ses
habitudes passées jean-claude regnault
marié deux enfants ouvriers tuyauteur
sur turbine à l'alstom son salaire 3200
francs par mois
après 17 années passées dans
l'entreprise demain matin il reprendra
son travail
la grève aura duré 58 joue beaucoup de
contacts humains des personnes quand
après tout les jours où le ravec qu'on
ne se connaît pas du tout des voyous
comme connaissais pas du tout maintenant
ça sera plus comme avant certainement
enfin je trouve quand même pas bien
c'est de faire la crêpe parce que
c'était foutu pour notre avenir n'avait
fait des projets point de vue vacances
fin d'année et pour l'habillement des
enfants si mais il ya une bonne
solidarité envers notre famille n'était
beaucoup aidé rentrée tous unis par la
grande porte
ce lundi matin à 7 heures c'était le
sentiment de jean claude regnault et de
tous les grévistes d'alstom ici personne
n'a oublié l'origine du conflit quand il
y a deux mois
la direction avait décidé d'offrir une
gratification à ses travailleurs
pour fêter le centenaire de l'entreprise
sans temps de travail et au choix une
bouteille de cognac une montre un stylo
ou une médaille
rené a n'a pu n'être considéré dawn est
fait à produire et sont destinés à faire
inspecter la grenade a pris la même
résolution de le punir l'auteur de deux
mois sans salaire c'est plus de 60
millions de francs perdus par les 7500
employés d'alstom perdu aussi pour
l'économie belfortaine c'est un peu à
tout cela que penser les ouvriers ce
matin quand les portes de l'usiné se
sont ouvertes
ouais
oh
allez
à
introduire dans prendre aujourd'hui oh
non non non je pense que c'est quand
même une belle rentrée bien haute
on rentre pas là t'es mort et le prouve
en continu à l'intérieur de résine le
plus dur compliqué connu alstom à
belfort se termine
il faudra au moins 15 jours pour que les
usines retrouve son rythme de production
demi-succès demi échec par le biais du
ministre du travail la direction a été
contrainte de faire des concessions
salaire minimal de de 1645 francs
programmation du 13e mois sur quatre ans
jours de congés supplémentaires
mais de l'avis général ce qui a compté
le plus dans ce bilan c'est l'évolution
des rapports humains
les ouvriers cadres ingénieurs ont
appris à se connaître
deux mois de grève ont fait plus que dix
ans de travail et rien ne sera plus
comme avant donc un conflit qui se
termine en revanche toujours la même
résolution chez les aiguilleurs du ciel
le mouvement se poursuit aussi dures
qu'auparavant et sans doute même jusqu'à
vendredi
voilà donc l'exemple de deux conflits
globaux et personnelle entre direction
et personnel relèvement du plafond du
livret à des caisses d'epargne il était
de 41 mille francs il sera désormais de
45 mille francs
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais 40
millions de français sont titulaires de
ce type de livrer 25 millions pour les
caisses d'epargne dit de l'écureuil et
15 millions pour les postes
la politique maintenant avec tout
d'abord la préparation du débat sur
l'avortement demain à l'assemblée ce que
les textes administrative appelle l
interruption volontaire de grossesse
débat a rendu nécessaire par l'aspect
provisoire de la loi votée il ya cinq
ans le projet de loi sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse ivg a été
adoptée par le parlement en décembre 74
pour une période de cinq ans allez c'est
en quelque sorte
il est donc nécessaire aujourd'hui de
voter à nouveau la loi peut être avec
quelques modifications pour la
reconduire cette fois définitivement la
loi de 74 prévoit la possibilité pour
une femme de recourir à liv et j'ai
pendant les dix premières semaines de sa
grossesse
l'intervention doit être obligatoirement
pratiqué par un médecin qui lui a la
possibilité de refuser l'ibg doit avoir
lieu dans un hôpital public
ou dans un établissement privé reconnu
enfin le médecin doit nécessairement
donner un délai de réflexion de huit
jours à sa patiente
passé ce délai la femme doit lui
confirmer par écrit sa volonté
d'apporter la notion clé de la loi de 74
c'est la notion de détresse dans
laquelle se trouvent certaines femmes
enceintes
le législateur a cru bon d'ajouter à
l'époque la loi garantit le respect de
tout être humain dès le commencement de
la vie il ne serait être porté atteinte
à ce principe qu'en cas de nécessité
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est donc pas un moyen de contraception
et surtout ce n'est pas un droit ce qui
explique qu'elles ne soient pas
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
exception faite pour 10% des femmes qui
ont pu bénéficier de l'aide médicale
gratuite
depuis 1974 le nombre des ivg a eu
tendance à se stabiliser
il y en a eu 149 mille en 1978 mais ces
chiffres qui ne tiennent pas compte des
avortements thérapeutiques ne tienne
toujours pas compte non plus des
avortements clandestins
va donc pour le dossier sur le plan
politique daniel brême jacques chirac a
fait savoir qu'il ne voterait pas par un
communiqué la savoir qu'il ne voterait
pas ce texte un texte il avait pourtant
appelé à voter il ya cinq ans alors faut
dire que c'est dans un climat un peu
particulier oui en novembre 74 le climat
à l'assemblée souvenez-vous était
extrêmement fiévreux et passionné et
monsieur chirac étaient à leur premier
ministre n'avait pas eu à voter ce texte
pas plus que les ministres puisque c'est
la tradition mais il avait encouragé
madame veil à défendre ce texte est la
majorité à le voter
et pourtant cette lettre de jacques
chirac pour les téléspectateurs downtown
d'antenne 2 n'est pas une surprise car
souvenez-vous à cartes sur table 2 avril
79 il y à peu près huit mois jacques
chirac jacques chirac disait déjà ce
qu'il dit aujourd'hui à savoir que la
loi qui avait été prévu pour les cas de
détresse était considérée maintenant
comme un moyen de contraception comme
les autres et que donc il ne la voterai
pas et que du reste il ya cinq ans il
avait déjà essayer de l'infléchir alors
monsieur chirac a bien dit ce matin que
sa prise de position était uniquement à
titre individuel est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle peut quand même
influencer les autres députés à écouter
les positions sont déjà tellement
tranché que je ne crois pas qu'elles les
changes mais en revanche je crois quand
même qu'il faut souligner les claques
jacques chirac a donné aujourd'hui à son
vote négatif sa prise de position
intervient au lendemain de ce qu'a dit
le président de la république à savoir
que cette loi était à caractère objectif
clairement sociale qu'elle était prévue
pour les femmes en détresse et qu'elle
ne devait en outre ou non en aucun cas
pardo inciter à l'avortement alors
plusieurs ministres dans les couloirs
m'ont dit ce qu'on peut craindre c'est
que cette prise de position qui va fasse
passer un vote de conscience une sorte
de vote personnelles sur un plan
politique et là évidemment la discussion
sur a rendu beaucoup plus difficile et
beaucoup plus délicates oreilles n'est
déjà pas tellement commode
bien sûr ça c'est pour le rpr du côté
des trois autres partis les positions
sont déjà acquises
oui je pense que il y aurait entre 40 et
45 % de votants pour à l'udf
vous savez qu'il y a liberté de vote et
liberté de discours donc la majorité
en revanche dans l'opposition les
communistes et les socialistes
voudraient qu'on assouplissent beaucoup
le texte
mais plutôt que de le voir disparaître
l'épée dans les reins en grognant je
crois qu'il va trop bien on vous
retrouve donc deux mains de niel brême
pour le début de ce débat sur
l'avortement vous retrouve un horaire
inhabituel car le journal aura lieu à
19h30 et non pas à 20 heures 19h30
puisque à 20h vous retrouverez le
présent un public qui sera questionné
par jean pierre elkabbach alain duhamel
et gérard saint paul adolfo suarez est
arrivé ce matin en france le chef du
gouvernement espagnol est accompagnée de
cinq ministres du pauvre l'importance
qu'il attache à cette visite
les relations franco espagnoles sont le
résultat d'un curieux mélange de bon
voisinage et de malentendus la vida de
lefaux sur elle permettra peut-être de
lever certaines équivoques notamment
celles qui pèsent sur la demande
d'adhésion espagnol au marché commun à
laufon suarez le premier ministre
espagnol que monsieur raymond barre
accueillait ce matin à orly et
probablement
l'homme politique le plus secret de son
pays un leader qui a tram et l'essentiel
du processus démocratique entre les
quatre murs de son bureau un chef de
parti qui se montre à peine pour les
campagnes électorales qui ne distille
ses interviews qu'au compte gouttes en
quelque sorte une énigme pour ses
propres concitoyens en se rendant
aujourd'hui à déjeuner à l'elysée
adolfo suarez à honorer avec un an de
retard
une invitation que valéry giscard
d'estaing avait lancé il y a dix huit
mois à madrid
quelles que soient les raisons qu'ils
aient poussé les espagnols a tardé à y
répondre elle non plus qu alourdir un
climat franco-espagnole déjà peu détendu
à madrid par exemple on a parfois assez
vivement reproché au gouvernement
français une certaine passivité
vis-à-vis des terroristes basques qui
trouvent refuge du côté français de la
frontière au pays basque
d'autre part l'espagne et qui frappent à
la porte du marché commun trouve sur la
route de bruxelles
les intérêts français car si sur le plan
des grands principes paris se réjouit de
l'admission prochaine de l'espagne au
sein du marché commun les choses
deviennent beaucoup plus difficile dès
qu'il s'agit d'aborder les problèmes
concrets or avec monsieur raymond barre
c'est bien de problèmes concrets que
l'on est venu parler monsieur soirée
êtes accompagné de cinq ministres ceux
qui sont en charge des dossiers les plus
polémiques commerce et agriculture
notamment plaider le dossier européen
avec succès c'est par exemple arrivé à
lever les inquiétudes que l'entrée de
l'espagne dans le marché commun fait
naître chez les spécialistes français
des productions méridionale
chez les vignerons du midi par exemple
qui n'ont pas tort de redouter la
concurrence des grandes régions
viticoles espagnoles où l'on fait du vin
en quantité importante du bon vin et ou
exporter et le souci numéro
reste que ces conversations les
premières du genre entre les deux
gouvernements ne devrait déboucher sur
aucun engagement
il s'agit en quelque sorte de fer
secteur par secteur l'inventaire des
points de friction entre la france et
l'espagne
ce n'est qu'après que la négociation
pourra s'engager
ouverture demain à paris du procès de
jean fabre de nationalité française jean
fabre et vous avez président du parti
radical italien
il comparaîtra demain devant le tribunal
permanent des forces armées pour
insoumission jan fabre est en prison
depuis un mois il est passible d'une
peine allant de deux mois à un an de
prison
alors cette récente affaire des
objecteurs de conscience de l'ambassade
de belgique également la soumission de
jan fabre jette la lumière sur un statut
mal connue alors voilà deux termes qui
se recouvrent et qui pourtant ne sont
pas l'expression de la même réalité ces
objections objecteurs de conscience et
un soumissions seront en effet deux
notions que l'on a tendance à confondre
alors vous faut rappeler que l'objection
de conscience est un droit reconnu à
chaque citoyen français par une loi du
21 décembre 63 et par certains articles
du code du service national je vous
passe fait référence droit que peuvent
faire valoir dit le texte les jeunes
gens qui avant leur incorporation se
déclare opposée en toutes circonstances
à l' usage des armes et ce en raison de
convictions religieuses ou
philosophiques
alors la procédure est la suivante dans
les 30 jours qui suivent l'appel de son
contingent l'objecteur doit adresser une
demande au ministre de la défense qui la
transmet à une commission composée d'un
magistrat qui préside la commission de
trois militaires de trois personnalités
désignées par le premier ministre
si la commission prend en considération
les raisons de l'objecteur celui-ci
accomplir un service civil de deux ans
c'est à dire le double du service
militaire dans une activité d'intérêt
national tels que l'office national des
forêts ou la services hospitaliers par
exemple alors il ya en france assez peu
d'objectifs de conscience en 60 18 sur
33 cents mille appelé et a eu mille
trente demandes et 980 cas accepter dire
qu'il n'ya pas de publicité à ce statut
non doit pas faire de publicité à ce
statut maladresse que la formation que
la donne actuellement ce n'est pas le
féliciter
ou alors je serait traduit devant un
tribunal ça sera parfait
l'insoumission donc est le deuxième
terme là celui celui qui ne se présente
pas à l'incorporation qui ne fait p qui
ne veut pas se présenter à la
coopération
alors les insoumis se partage en deux
corps est intéressant de voir que
légiférer si les juridictions ne sont
pas les mêmes les objecteurs à qui la
commission a dit non a refusé et qui ne
se commandent ya je présente pas sont
poursuivis par des tribunaux civils et
sont passibles d'une peine d'aaland
deux mois à un an de prison et ceux qui
n'ont rien demandé qui ne se sont pas
présentés et qui n'est qu'ils ont
poursuivi par les tribunaux militaires
cette fois sont également passibles de
deux mois et un an de prison et vous
allez voir que leur fille de leur nombre
n'est pas très important puisqu'en 78
selon les derniers chiffres connus
il n'y a eu en france que 331 1 soubie
condamne donc jean fabre rodez mais nous
le verrons en tout cas vous allez sur ce
procès pour nous et nous retrouverons à
19h30 une fois encore je le rappelle la
fusée européenne
enfin operationnal opérationnel par noël
porte vous le savez un autre français
ariane il y avait encore un petit
problème pour le troisième étage de
cette fusée
il a été résolu aujourd'hui le premier
lancement d'ariane aura lieu le 15
décembre si tout va bien et fin mai elle
pourra envoyer son premier satellite
dans le ciel prix littéraire suit pas de
surprise aujourd'hui pour le médicis et
femina les favoris ont en effet gagné le
médicis revient à claude durand pour la
nuit zoologique et pierre moinot a reçu
le prix femina avec le guetteur dhombres
étrange livre que celui de pierre moinot
fourmillements de symbole c'est une
manière de quête d'une paix intérieure
que notre société nous empêche de
trouver c'est aussi la découverte de la
nature par un homme surmené
bref il s'agit à la fois d'une histoire
romantique et d'un roman sociétés
armance société dans la mesure où
justement mon personnage
fui la société et il la connaît bien
puisque c'est un rédacteur en chef d'un
grand quotidien qui voit à la fois lol
et chaque jour le le grand dérèglement
les affaires du monde et qui ne peut pas
il trouver une réponse satisfaisante
et puis aussi c'est un roman de
solitaire puis c'est un homme qui s'en
va dans une forêt pour essayer de
trouver un certain nombre de réponses à
des questions qui se posent depuis très
longtemps ou pour essayer de déterminer
les questions qui n'ont pas de réponse
parce qu'il n'y a que la nature qui pose
les vraies questions et qui apportent
les vraies réponses
il n'y a pas que la nature qui pose les
vraies questions puisque son c'est nous
qui nous déposions mais en tout cas je
pense est profondément que lorsqu'il ya
des vraies réponses on peut les trouver
dans la nature y est ce que vous pensez
que le monde aujourd'hui tous les gens
qui vous entourent qui nous entourent
ont la possibilité comme votre héros de
s'enfoncer dans la forêt profonde pour
vivre espèces d'initiation non
s'enfoncer ça dépend si vous prenez la
foire est dans sa signification
symbolique
oui je crois que chacun de nous peut un
certain nombre de sa vie et s'il s'il
son existence n'est pas si dur qu'il
puisse y ménager un certain moment de
réflexion peut s'enfoncer dans sa propre
forêt pour faire le point pour y trouver
ses propres réponses prix médicis
étranger a été attribué à l'écrivain
cubain alejo carpentier pour la hardt et
l'ombre claude durand le lauréat du
médicis français sera l'invité d'hervé
claude à 23h30
marcel l'herbier est mort aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 91 ans celui qui avait fondé la
cinémathèque française avec henri mangwa
et qui fut le premier directeur de lydec
l'institut des hautes études signaux
graphiques avait à partir des années 20
claudin philippe vraiment profondément
influencé le cinéma france oui et on
peut dire qu'il a vécu suffisamment pour
voir revenir à lui un certain nombre de
jeunes cinéphiles après une période où
ces films ont été un peu oubliée il a eu
la chance de vivre suffisamment pour
voir revenir à lui
des gens très admiratif en particulier
effectivement de sa période des années
20 avec surtout l'argent qui est un très
très très grand film l'inhumaine
s'apaisa période du muet il a été acheté
à l'oci sur le muel parlera où il a
beaucoup d y avait 50 filles meyers est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé toute sa vie
et qu'on peut définir tout simplement
comme étant un des cinéastes de l'âge
d'or je dire que pour nous signifie la
mort de marcel l'herbier représente
quelque chose comme la mort de cet ajout
un metteur en scène très jeune il a
cogné a débuté à 20 ans et à 25 ans il
dirigeait les foules de l'argent devant
la bourse de paris il arrivait à faire
avec des images avec une caméra de la
pellicule et et et des milliers de
figurants il arriver à faire quelque
chose qui était de l'ordre de l'opéra
visuel et on sait qu'il a été à
l'origine du lancement de la carrière de
beaucoup d'acteurs within près louis
l'aï là et puis des pyjamas rêve c'est
ça et puis il a aussi fait entrer fait
venir au cinéma
les quantités de gens qu'il admirait des
musiciens des décorateurs des
architectes et si on regarde le
générique de l'inhumaine par exemple on
trouve paul poiret qui était le grand
couturier l'époque on trouve mallet
stevens était le grand architecte de
l'époque on retrouve fernand léger qui
venait construire des décors exactement
comme il aurait pas une toile sur le
plateau s'il ne faut retenir qu'un seul
film qu'elle vous gardent l'argent
certainement mais lui tenait à toute son
oeuvre remercie la météo maintenant le
temps était couvert de la bretagne aux
ardennes avec des pluies des vents assez
forts demain et bien sûr les régions de
la haute normandie sur l'alsace et sur
le jura le temps sera doux avec de
nombreux nuages qui amèneront parfois
vous le voyez la pluie sur le reste du
pays après dissipation des brouillards
matinaux comme on dit du soleil avec
quelques petits passages nuageux plus
nombreux au nord de la loire au prochain
rendez vous avec l'information tout
d'abord ce soir hervé claude à 23h30
demain à 12h45 antennes 2010 qui sera
présentée par daniel bilalian au cours
de cette émission la suite du débat
public que nous avons lancé depuis dix
jours maintenant sur le problème
nucléaire et à ce propos la direction de
edf a démenti cet après-midi l'existence
d'une fissure sur une tubulure à la
centrale nucléaire de dampierre 2 c'est
une affirmation qui avait été évoqué
dans l'une de nos auditions publiques de
ce journal d'antenne 2010 à 12h45 avant
de refermer tout à fait ce journal je
voudrais vous parler à nouveau de
chinois puisque nous avons ouvert sur
eux
et bien sachez qu'ils ont déjà gagné une
médaille ils viennent dans le fait de
découvrir le secret de la longévité
alors si vous voulez vivre centenaire il
paraît qu'il faut manger peut boire peu
c'est évident faire un travail pénible
ça paraît moins évident et surtout être
optimiste c'est ce qu'a révélé
aujourd'hui l' agence chine nouvelle
voilà je vous quitte je laisse passer
une petite page de publicité car après
vous allez voir en question de temps
nous ne serons pas du tout optimiste
bonsoir à tous à demain 19h30 n'oublie
pas dignes de leurs 30 et à 20 heures